en la medida que pasan los días el agua
ha estado bajando en la ciudad de gersón
y el resultado de estas casas
especialmente las que están ubicadas al
lado del río es esto Todo queda
destruido se ven zapatos
muy pronto
ese martes de la destrucción viene a
rescatar a mi tío estuvimos aquí hasta
las dos de la tarde hasta que el agua
empezó a subir volvía a las 7 de la
noche a buscar el gato y el agua estaba
ya al nivel de las ventanas el agua ya
tenía todo cubierto y era imposible
entrar
Esta es la época de la primavera en
gersón y este rosal en especial Estaba
totalmente florecido Este es un ejemplo
de la altura del agua todo quedó
destruido allí no se puede entrar solo
quiero mostrar desde afuera no quedó
nada
[Música]
ellos siguen atacando constantemente
sabe cómo nos movemos por la ciudad
cuando está tranquilo salimos a la calle
de lo contrario no recientemente me tuve
que quedar en el gran teatro Y me tuve
que esconder allí porque hubo un ataque
tan grande que es imposible de describir
los habitantes en la cercanía del Río
nieper en gerson han llevado tal vez las
peores consecuencias después de que las
tropas ucranianas hicieran retirar a las
fuerzas rusas a finales de noviembre
desde entonces la ciudad es
permanentemente atacada aquí
especialmente en esta zona de la ciudad
y este hombre nos cuenta que su hijo
murió en una de esas tantos ataques el
pasado 24 de diciembre
mi hijo salió a comprar cosas para comer
fue asesinado el 24 de diciembre Mi
cumpleaños es el 25 él fue a comprar
cosas para celebrar el día después
nos han permitido vivir en un centro de
acogida mientras que pasa todo esto